can't innovate anymore my ass
the success of Apple's Mac Pro hasn't
really been the greatest in the past
decade with the 2013 trashcan Mac Pro
being a failure for its overheating
problems and the most recent 2019 Mac
Pro tower being quickly destroyed by the
new Apple silicon Max but now apple is
ready to usher in a new age of the Mac
Pro fully modernized and ready for the
future with the fastest Apple silicon
chip they've ever created and I now
believe we have enough evidence for this
new Mac Pro to be revealed at WWDC in
just over a week from today so let's
jump right into the biggest pieces of
evidence ones that aren't just from
random leakers like this unverifiable
Source on Twitter who says a new 15-inch
MacBook gear Mac Pro and headset are
coming at WWDC even though I actually
believe him in April Nicholas Alvarez
discovered some code within find my
configuration showing three unannounced
desktop Mac models which could possibly
be an updated Mac Studio a Mac Pro or
both as you can see two model numbers
are similar 14 13 and 14 14 which could
correspond to both an M2 Max and M2
Ultra Max studio and then the 14 8
number might be the Mac Pro going
further back in February Apple filed a
new Bluetooth 5.3 listing which could be
hinting at the release of some new Mac
products including the 15-inch MacBook
Air and the Mac Pro and this makes sense
because they already had the new M2
family MacBook Pros and Mac Minis on the
listing which all have Bluetooth 5.3
already now there was another huge Leak
with an Apple's beta code but first I
want to show you guys a massive leak
update from Mark German who was recently
on the Mac Rumors podcast but before we
get into that I've got to talk about the
best shoes I've ever had from our
partner vessi a brand that makes 100
waterproof shoes and yes they really are
a hundred percent waterproof when I
bought this pair just before winter I
could literally walk through snow even
snow blowing my driveway and washing
them under the sink the inside stays
completely dry which is mind-blowing for
such a comfortable slip-on shoe we also
recently went through the rainy season
when I could walk through puddles and
wet morning grass with a hundred percent
dry socks I Honestly Love Bessie so much
that I bought my wife two pairs the
Chelsea boots and now another pair for
the spring being lightweight and very
comfortable for everything including
enjoying our e-bikes and especially
mountain biking they're literally the
best shoes I've ever had so check out a
variety of styles by using the link
below to save up to 30 with vesi's
Memorial Day sale and in case you missed
it you can still get 15 off your order
with the code Max Tech at checkout so
use that link to pick up your favorite
style of bessies today now getting back
to what Mark Herman said about the Mac
Pro just listen to this clip and I think
part of the reason why you're seeing
these M that 15-inch MacBook uh air
being an M2 and then the M3 coming later
is because you don't want to launch an
M3 before you launch the M2 Ultra chip
coming in uh the Mac Pro and then in
terms of the conflict with the Max
studio uh what I believe is we're not
going to see a new Mac Studio until the
M3 generation at the earliest so I don't
believe there'll be an M2 Ultra Max
studio so Mark is basically saying three
things here number one is that the Mac
Pro is still coming this year number two
is that the M2 Ultra Mac Pro must come
before the M3 chip and number three is
that the Max studio will not be getting
updated until the m 3 Ultra chip is
ready and the thing about the regular M3
chip is that it could be released as
soon as this fall and in that case Apple
absolutely must reveal the Mac Pro at
WWDC however there is a chance that the
M3 gets delayed until the spring next
year and then Apple could wait until the
fall to reveal the Mac Pro which could
be why Mark personally doesn't think
it's coming this June now some people
online were actually speculating that
Apple might even skip the M2 Ultra chip
altogether saying that there's no
guarantee that Apple even built in the
same Ultra Fusion Bridge into the M2 Max
die like they did with the M1 Max which
they revealed last year in March however
ta Tech 15 posted a real photo of the M2
Max die on Twitter and if you look
really closely in past the black brush
you can see the M2 Max dies interconnect
meant to create the M2 Ultra so I fully
believe we're getting the M2 Ultra chip
with the Mac Pro this year but getting
back to the major leaks 9 to 5 Mac found
references to a new compute module
device within iOS 16.4 code which is
likely coming sometime this year based
on the timing of this leak what it
sounds like to me and many others is
something like an add-in computational
card with apple silicon which can
upgrade or boost the power of a device
now at first many people thought it was
meant for powering Apple's VR headset
but we recently got a leak of the
headsets bill of materials with many
different components including two main
chips those components all total out to
fourteen hundred dollars or around
sixteen hundred dollars with shipping
costs included in terms of the expense
for apple and there there is no mention
anywhere about a Compu module since the
headset is meant to be stand alone so
because of that it's likely that these
modules are destined for the Mac Pro
allowing you to buy potentially a Bare
Bones Mac Pro Tower chassis and then
upgrade your Mac Pro with these modules
over the years instead of having to buy
the entire chassis every single time and
apparently Benjamin on Twitter found an
apple patent that seems to confirm
support within a Mac Pro for slottable
GPU cards mentioning assignable M gpus
and kick slots we also had hachitech on
Twitter Who currently lacks a credible
track record but he began talking about
the customizable Apple silicon cards
days before the exclusive iOS 16.4 leak
found by nine to five Mac apparently he
says Apple has been building modules
using M1 or M2 CP few variants with
different layouts of memory performance
efficiency and Graphics cores and it'll
work alongside the existing SOC he also
said that Apple might have a new chip
named X1 with a base configuration of 48
GPU cores but it might just be a
placeholder name since his Source came
across it via a printed diagnostic of
CPU performance and finally we also have
a big update from a leaker with a solid
track record the Mac Rumors Forum user
amethyst who previously leaked the Max
studio days before anybody else and he
was completely right back in January he
confirmed that three months later Apple
sent his Source another Mac Pro
prototype which is still based on the
2019 Mac Pro Tower it has six PCI
Express slots and has no user
replaceable Ram so it seems like that's
the design Apple is sticking with on top
of that there will apparently be a
monster of a chip for the new Mac Pro
hinting at an M2 extreme with four M2
Max dies like amethyst thinks it's
getting although Mark German said that
was canceled so I'm not really sure but
the huge update came on March 4th with
confirmation that it'll use an M2 Ultra
chip for sure with Apple trying to push
the performance cores to 4.2 gigahertz
with success but with much more power
consumption and the heatsink can easily
handle the heat however they haven't
decided just yet if they'll stick to
that much performance so with that said
I think we have sufficient evidence to
assume that Apple will at least reveal
the Mac Pro at WWDC even if they don't
launch it right away however keep in
mind that Mark gurman doesn't think it's
getting revealed just yet so I could be
wrong but you let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and check out
those two other WWDC leak videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one
foreign